now we've about now 3 500 troops
redeployed in afghanistan as of tonight
hundreds of thousands of people are
trying to get out china is poised to
exploit the situation the u.s border
under siege with covet-infected migrants
and
we don't have an actual president in
charge
yesterday joe biden darted back to d.c
from camp david read for about what 19
minutes
then took no questions
and skedaddled off the podium
oh and then he went back to camp david
now
answers were supposed to be provided
today by biden's national security
a young chap who looks like he's running
for student council
but i sure as hell wouldn't vote for him
after this performance
when
a civil war comes to an end with an
opposing force marching on the capitol
there are going to be scenes of chaos
there are going to be lots of people
leaving the country that is not
something that can be
fundamentally avoided
translation
happens
and what about getting all those
americans out of afghanistan
i'm not going to comment on
hypotheticals what i'm going to do is
stay focused on the task at hand which
is getting as many people out as rapidly
as possible and we will take that day by
day we have asked them all to come to
the airport to get on flights and take
them home that's what we intend to do
nintendo get to the airport don't worry
about those taliban people attacking
everyone on the way well a few hours ago
sullivan kind of the doogie houser of
the diplomatic national security set he
tried to clarify in a tweet claiming
that what he meant to say was that they
intend and they will get all americans
who want to leave out of afghanistan
okay
maybe lead with that next time around
well that wasn't the only shocking
revelation today apparently our most
experienced foreign policy president
ever
was so busy trying out trying to figure
out how to use those tv remotes at camp
david that he had not spoken to another
world leader during the crisis that he
helped create
he has not yet spoken with any other
world leaders of
myself secretary blinken uh several
other senior members of the team have
been engaged on a regular basis with
foreign counterparts and we intend to do
so in the coming days
he's in charge in other words now after
feeling the blowback for obvious reasons
the white house scrambled to put out
word that biden had finally picked up
the phone to talk with with british
prime minister boris johnson
in other words
they had to do cleanup
for the guy who was supposed to do
cleanup for the president
these people are totally incompetent now
remember this is our national security
team
and wasn't foreign policy kind of
biden's thing
this is a moment that requires strong
steady stable leadership we need someone
tested and trusted around the world this
is a moment for joe biden a president
with the experience to lead i've worked
on these issues as long as anyone
i've been throughout afghanistan during
this war while the war was going on from
kabul to kandahar
to the kunar valley
i've traveled there on four different
occasions
i met with the people
i spoken to the leaders
kabul kandahar
oh nice
that's good now he was still under the
delusion that afghanistan
was a stable country
joe has been sleeping a lot longer than
we thought
i thought america was back didn't he say
that i thought biden and his team were
foreign policy gurus
who could totally get other countries to
help the united states
i thought they had a plan
experience is key they said biden would
calm things down after trump and get us
back to the regular order of things
joe biden brought with him uh to the
white house his expertise on foreign
policy and national security joel biden
comes in with literally a world of
experience it's the entire cast of
national security people who were on
that stage yesterday with the
president-elect joe biden it's
competence experience insight humility
they said that trump had to be defeated
because he was too green too arrogant a
little brash he made things more
dangerous they said
foreign leaders didn't listen to him
they said
but all of it was a lie
we've just suffered one of the most
humiliating defeats in american history
a defeat made worse by their utter
inability to predict anything with
accuracy
and their response is that biden isn't
talking to anyone
shouldn't biden be talking to everyone
and trying to assure them that he
actually knows what he's doing
even if the biden team doesn't think he
can do the job shouldn't they at least
pretend that he can do it
they could have given him some flash
cards or something to read on the phone
anything
but no
we just had radio silence
the team of lincoln sullivan and klein
has plainly failed
the notion that they could run the
country while biden hid from public view
has been proven false
on the military front general white rage
milly
secretary crt austin
should have already been terminated
they're being out maneuvered everywhere
in the world and it shows
democrats and republicans on the hill
should all be demanding that biden clean
house and bring in much better people to
get this situation under control we
can't take these three uh much longer we
can't take three weeks of this much less
three more years of this
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else